last Friday in the state of Ohio third
way the you know renowned centrist
Democratic think-tank hosted this event
in Ohio where they got the Democrats
together along with some wealthy donors
to talk about what to do about this
progressive revolution happening here in
the United States specifically
Alexandria ok Jie Cortez
that woman has come along and just
revolutionized American politics she has
gotten people act if she has given
people hope and she is talking about the
issues that people absolutely care about
again whether they're left right center
or anything in between she seems to
understand it and she gets it and that's
freaking out these corporate centrist
Democrats now before I get into this
story please understand I am NOT saying
that anybody who's a member of the DNC
is a corporatist or a centrist we have
too many in there that are though okay
and they're the ones who went to Ohio at
this private invitation only thing put
on by third way to try to figure out how
to stop this progressive tide from
taking over the United States
here is what representative Tim Ryan
from the good state of Ohio had to say
at that meeting you're not going to make
me hate somebody just because they're
rich I want to be rich and everybody
laughed
here's the thing Tim if I can call you
Tim yeah we don't hate people because
they're rich we dislike the inequality
in the United States if you can get rich
great get rich live the dream
everybody's rooting for you but don't
screw over every single person that
you've ever met in your life or anybody
that's ever worked for you to get rich
that's the problem we have nobody's mad
that Jeff Bezos has money everybody's
mad that Jeff Bezos has money and it's
making his employees pee in bottles
because they're not even allowed to get
bathroom
that's the problem wealth isn't evil
evil people just happen to be getting
wealthy in the United States there is a
big difference there nobody cares if you
have money nobody cares if you're rich
we just care that the people who helped
put you there get taken care of as well
and that's the part that's missing from
the equation that is the part that these
centrist Third Way Democrats don't
understand they try to reframe the issue
and say oh these communists these young
socialists they just hate people having
money no I mean how dumb do you have to
be to think that you can fool this
country by saying something like that
but that is what Tim Ryan did here that
is what that meeting was about with
their wealthy billionaire donors and it
completely misses the point and helps
explain why that blue wave this November
that everybody's expecting if they keep
talking like this it won't exist the way
they think it will but that is all the
time we have for today on today's bonus
show though we're gonna be talking about
the fact that FEMA has finally admitted
just how badly they screwed up Puerto
Rico we've got Trump staffers whining
about the fact that nobody wants to date
them still and hey Fox News freaked out
after they realized they booked the
wrong Democrat as a guest if you enjoyed
what I had to say today you can follow
me on twitter at baron balanced you can
also check me out on youtube at
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire I
want to thank David and Patrick for
letting me sit in today hope everyone
has a wonderful day David we'll be back
tomorrow thank you very much